une annonce dont qui avait été prise
lors d'une assemblée générale le 20
juillet est ce que vous avez eu le temps
de vous préparer à cette décision ou est
ce que c'est une mauvaise surprise pour
les 290 salariés
on avait le temps jours jours on avait
le temps de on a eu le temps de se
préparer mais de l'accepter c'est un peu
compliqué 40 ans de travail dans un
établissement et d'être d'être licencié
c'est compliqué surtout qu'ils avaient
d'autres d'autres possibilités mais ça
n'a pas été choisi tout le monde a
choisi de nous fermer
voilà c'est non on est pas on a on se
prépare pas à faire mais c'est pas c'est
pas possible on a tous envie de
continuer à garder notre emploi et dans
quel état d'esprit sont les salariés
alors les fours les fours ont été
arrêtés mercredi dernier aujourd'hui il
y avait un peu moins de colère la colère
était un petit peu passé on va essayer
on essaye surtout de bien accompagner de
ce qui va se passer après on était des
fondeurs on va devenir des chômeurs donc
faut comment comment le passé le cap
c'est pas facile surtout qu'il ya des
des collègues ont 55 ans 52 ans et des
ageux difficile sur un bassin
châtelleraudais déjà sinistré en termes
d'industrie alors la fermeture du site
industriel nourrit de fortes inquiétudes
c'est vrai dans la commune et pour tout
le bassin châtelleraudais
est-ce qu'il va y avoir un impact
important sur la région selon vous ah
oui c'est un gros buy va on a vraiment
l'impression qu'en plus on est le début
on est on est peut-être les premiers
nous sommes liés à l'automobile les
décisions européennes et
et du gouvernement actuel d'arrêter tout
ce qui était sur le moteur thermique
fait que tout le bassin châtelleraudais
et on a des analyses in valeo ont
analysé une magnétique on allait
fonderie aluminium nos voisins qui
travaille pour aussi pour renault pour
l'automobile mais l'automobile thermique
un bain il risque d'y avoir une grosse
vague de licenciements et le bassin
châtelleraudais
on n'a vraiment pas besoin est-ce que
vous avez des reproches à faire au
gouvernement aujourd'hui
ah oui oui on a un gros reproche à faire
c'est c est eux qui nous ont mis ce
groupe
dieu du riche actionnaires femme gît
gupta et c'est monsieur macron qu'il
l'avait peut amener ça devait être le
sauveur de l'industrie
en fin de compte c c'est quelqu'un qui
est en train de tout laisser tomber
et pour preuve l'état mais tellement
d'argent pour nous accompagner c'est que
ces signes qui se sentent vraiment
responsable on met pas d'argent quand on
n'est pas responsable
merci à vous alain delabos sacre était
assez à ceux de la fonderie deux pointes
au mercy pour avoir été en direct avec
nous sur rt france